something that's so interesting to me
about your career that's something I
really admire you for is it after
Malcolm ended you decided you sort of
decided I've had it with I don't
necessarily want to be in the spotlight
I want to try these radically different
things and a lot of people in your
position I've a seat enough to do it for
money but wouldn't want to say okay I'm
on to the next show I'm on to the next
role but you took up such interesting
stuff I know like you and almost like
things that like sports
you know racecar driving which you know
no one probably would have called you
would have done no I and and drumming
but they were things were you sort of
were a little bit in the background oh
yeah I mean like obviously being an
actor being on you know Malcolm and
Malcolm Miller the center of attention
your you know on the show everyone sees
you you know you that's what you do but
I kind of went into the racing but sure
you're still performing in front of
crowds but like you have a helmet on
you're in the car it's really just you
see a little feel little shelter yeah
and then I joined a band called Kings
fall I toured with for a bunch of years
and I'm the drummer you know like no one
looks at the drummer you know I mean
you're like at the front man sorry man
nobody nobody nobody looks at the
drummer
he doesn't even get it single now it
doesn't even look they can't even put a
camera on it now yeah they had one
camera shooting seven guys now they're
swinging it around oh there is
but then James worm Worth's a rate
drummer I went from that to like I
didn't even want to be on stage anymore
I love like the business side of the
band so much I just manage a band called
astral a so now like I'm like I mean on
stage I'm in the back making phone calls
making sure everything's cool yeah so
like you know my personality has become
like I don't want to be the center of
attention not that I don't want it but
like it's just I'm more shy yeah but you
know like I want to own an accounting
firm like that's that's that's what is
my dream like ranky that is every
child's dream we wish you good luck with
that yeah
you